This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Which dog do you think is bigger? Fido? Or Rover? Both of these dogs are making the exact same sound. They're barking. But the vocal quality of the barks easily gives away the size of the dog. The lower pitch dog is a large, sane Bernard. But the vocal quality of the barks easily gives away the size of the dog.
这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。你觉得哪只狗更大？菲多？还是罗孚？这两只狗发出的声音完全一样。它们都在叫。但狗叫声的音质很容易泄露狗的体型。声音较低的那只是一只大型圣伯纳犬。但狗叫声的音质很容易泄露狗的体型。
The lower-pitched dog is a large, sane Bernard, while high-pitched Phydo is a small Chihuahua. Throughout nature, the vocalizations of different animals offer clues. From birds to baboon, it sounds you hear can tell you useful things about an animal's size, its intentions, even its role in its social hierarchy. But is any of this true for humans? Does the human voice convey anything important about who's up and who's down? At one level, the answer is no. We determine rank and pecking order using sophisticated language and cultural norms. In politics, we select leaders through elections.
声音较低的那只是一只大型圣伯纳犬，而声音较高的菲多是一只小型吉娃娃。在整个自然界中，不同动物的发声都提供了线索。从鸟类到狒狒，你听到的声音可以告诉你关于动物体型、意图甚至其在社会等级中地位的有用信息。但这对于人类来说也是真的吗？人类的声音是否传达了关于谁占上风、谁处于下风的重要信息？从某种层面来看，答案是否定的。我们利用复杂的语言和文化规范来决定等级和秩序。在政治中，我们通过选举来选择领导人。
But at the same time, humans are also animals. Today on Hidden Brain, the tension between our modern complex political systems and ancient biological rules that tell us who's in charge. Nonverbal vocal signals that do not necessarily cano language or grammar the way that you and I would understand it as human beings are conveying a great deal of information. I want to be the people's governor. I will work on it. I can be even my soft voice. It might be a bit more effective at getting conservative things done.
但与此同时，人类也是动物。今天的 Hidden Brain 探讨了我们现代复杂的政治体系与告诉我们谁当家作主的古老生物学规则之间的张力。非语言的声音信号并不一定以你我作为人类所理解的方式包含语言或语法，它们却在传达大量的信息。我想成为人民的州长。我会为此努力。我甚至可以用我柔和的声音。这可能在办成保守派的事情时更有效。
And what we've done is we have taken that model, and we have applied it to politics and to political candidates. Some years ago, the political scientist Casey Kllaafstad was hanging out with his wife, Rindy Anderson. She's a biologist who studies songbird vocalizations. They were watching TV. They noticed something that connected her interest in bird sounds with his interest in politics. Yeah, I can picture us, you know, lying on the couch, you know, you know, mid evening, you know, and
我们所做的是，我们将这个模式应用到了政治和政治候选人身上。几年前，政治学家凯西·克洛夫斯塔德和他的妻子琳迪·安德森在一起。她是一位研究鸣禽发声的生物学家。他们当时在看电视。他们注意到了一些事情，将她对鸟类叫声的兴趣与他对政治的兴趣联系了起来。是的，我可以想象我们，你知道，躺在沙发上，你知道，你知道，傍晚时分，你知道，然后
We're just sort of flipping through channels and we landed on Fox or CNN. I forget which and you know my my wife brought up the fact that you know It seems like the women that our Broadcasters tend to have a lower timber voice is there there something to this? In it, at the time, it seemed very anecdotal. Obviously, it's not scientific, but it let us down this path. The path it led them down was to explore whether there was any connection between the world of animal vocalizations and the world of human vocalizations. Many studies have explored the idea that grunts and roars and squeaks tell us useful things
我们只是在换台，然后停在了福克斯或CNN。我忘了是哪个，你知道，我妻子提出这样一个事实，你知道，似乎我们广播员中的女性往往声音音调较低，这里面有什么原因吗？当时，这看起来非常具有轶事色彩。显然，这并非科学，但这引领我们走上了这条道路。这条道路引导他们去探索动物发声世界与人类发声世界之间是否存在某种联系。许多研究探讨了呼噜声、咆哮声和尖叫声能告诉我们有用信息的观点
about the size of animals and their social dominance. Casey and Rindi began to look for empirical evidence that connected the human voice with electoral and political outcomes. In one recent study, Casey told me he analyzed the voices of candidates running in the 2012 election for the US House of Representatives. I'm Rodney Day. I'm Shizinta Albenay and I approve this message. I'm Dr. Almebarra and I approve this message. I'm Jim Mournacy. I'm Dan Mfaey and I approve this message. I asked him what he found. What we found is that both men and women with lower pitch voices were more likely to win,
关于动物的体型和它们的社会统治地位。凯西和琳迪开始寻找将人类声音与选举和政治结果联系起来的实证证据。凯西告诉我，在最近的一项研究中，他分析了2012年美国众议院选举中候选人的声音。我是罗德尼·戴。我是希津塔·阿尔贝内，我赞成这条信息。我是阿尔梅巴拉博士，我赞成这条信息。我是吉姆·穆尔纳西。我是丹·姆费伊，我赞成这条信息。我问他发现了什么。我们发现，无论男女，声音较低的候选人更有可能获胜，
and we found that that is even the case in terms of whether they won or lost, or the vote share, the percentage of the votes that they won. Cut it any way you want, they were more likely to win. And then we can even control for things like campaign spending, the gender of the candidate, the ideological persuasion of the district that they are running in, things of that nature. We threw the kitchen sink at it and we tried to explain away the voice pitch effect and we could not. At one level, Casey says, this is surprising. At another, it is entirely unsurprising. Nonverbal vocal signals are endemic throughout the animal kingdom, whether it's human beings,
我们发现，无论是在输赢方面，还是在得票份额（即他们赢得的选票百分比）方面，情况都是如此。不管你怎么看，他们都更有可能获胜。然后我们甚至可以控制诸如竞选支出、候选人性别、他们所在的选区意识形态倾向等因素。我们把所有能用的方法都用上了，试图解释声音音调的影响，但我们无法排除它。凯西说，从某种层面来看，这令人惊奇。从另一方面来看，这完全在意料之中。非语言的声音信号在整个动物界都广泛存在，无论是人类，
or sombers, or anybody in between, whether it's the hiss of the snake, the roar of the red deer, the bark of a dog, you know, snarrel of a dog, things that you see every day that do not necessarily cano-language your grammar the way that you and I would understand it as human beings are conveying a great deal of information. And what we've done is we have taken that model and we have applied it to politics and to political candidates. So when you think about politics, which is of course a world in which you live and breathe, the conventional way of thinking about it is that we choose people to be our leaders because they have qualities of leadership, they have a track record of experience,
还是鸣禽，或者介于两者之间的任何人，无论是蛇的嘶嘶声、马鹿的咆哮声、狗的叫声，你知道，狗的低吼声，你每天都能看到的那些不一定像你我作为人类所理解的那样包含语言或语法的东西，都在传达着大量的信息。而我们所做的是，我们将这个模型应用到了政治和政治候选人身上。因此，当你想到政治时，这当然是你生活和呼吸的世界，传统的思考方式是，我们选择人们成为我们的领导人，是因为他们具备领导才能，他们有丰富的经验记录，
they are skilled communicators, they have great vision about the future. And I think many people would say, voice has nothing to do with it. You know, the candidate's voice, high pitch, low pitch, how can that possibly matter? So we as human beings make very thin, impressionistic judgments. And I will equivocate to you and say that yes, that many myriad other things line up to influence who we vote for. And the biggest thing for me as a political scientist is partisanship, right? If you're a Democrat, you're gonna have a priori vote
他们是熟练的沟通者，他们对未来有宏伟的愿景。我想许多人会说，声音与此毫无关系。你知道，候选人的声音，高音还是低音，怎么可能重要呢？所以我们作为人类，会做出非常肤浅、印象式的判断。我要向你含糊其辞地说，是的，许多其他繁杂的因素共同影响着我们投票给谁。对我作为一个政治学家来说，最大的因素是党派倾向，对吧？如果你是民主党人，你就会先验地投票
for Democrats. If you're a Republican, you're gonna vote for a Republican. But let's say for example, it's a municipal race. That's nonpartisan. You have no prior information. You don't have anything judge on off the cuff. Now we start to grasp but other straws. So it's not to say that we have the Rosetta Stone if you will for electoral politics, but it's one thing that we want to add as a piece to the puzzle. And on top of that, not just a voice pitch or whatever, but to acknowledge the fact that we are animals,
支持民主党人。如果你是共和党人，你就会投票支持共和党人。但比方说，这是一场市政选举。那是无党派的。你没有任何先验信息。你没有任何凭空判断的依据。现在我们开始抓住其他救命稻草。所以这并不是说我们拥有选举政治的“罗塞塔石碑”，但这是我们想要添加到拼图中的一块。最重要的是，不仅仅是声音音调或别的什么，而是要承认这样一个事实：我们是动物，
and that we act on animal instincts. When you see where animals and we act on animal instincts, are you saying that in some ways things that might be written deep into our you know the algorithms of how our brain works things that you know I call the hidden brain the unconscious mind things that we're not aware of can't shape our behavior in the conscious world when it comes to politics Absolutely, right? We these things are affecting us Whether we are conscious of it or not,
并且我们受动物本能的驱使。当你看到我们是动物且受动物本能驱使时，你是否在某种程度上认为，那些可能深深写入我们大脑运作算法中的东西，也就是我所说的隐藏大脑、无意识思维，那些我们没有意识到的东西，能否在涉及政治的意识世界中塑造我们的行为？完全正确，对吧？这些东西正在影响着我们，无论我们是否有意识到底，
you know, Alex Toterov, which I'm sure you're familiar with his work, showed that if you give an image of a candidate for point two seconds, that an individual is willing, enable to make a judgment about that individual's competence, and at a rate greater than chance, is that rating is able to predict whether that individual wins.
你知道，阿列克谢·托特罗夫（我相信你对他的作品很熟悉）表明，如果你给出一张候选人的照片0.2秒，个人就愿意并能够对该个体的能力做出判断，并且其准确率高于随机猜测，这种评分能够预测该个人是否会胜出。
So whether it's vision, whether it's voice, whatever, we are judging on a very thin basis. What explains the dichotomy between the way we think about the way we make these decisions and the way we actually might make these decisions? So I think the thing that a lot of people find surprising is that when the total of study finds that these very brief exposure to images or you're finding that very brief, you know, hearing different kinds of voices or pictures that this has in effect, you know, maybe a small but a measurable effect on electoral outcomes. People are surprised by it because they think,
所以无论是愿景、声音还是其他什么，我们的判断都是基于非常肤浅的依据。是什么解释了我们对决策方式的看法与我们实际决策方式之间的二分法？所以我认为很多人觉得惊讶的是，当托特罗夫的研究发现，对图像的这种短暂接触，或者你发现的这种非常短暂的、你知道的听到不同种类的声音或图片，会对选举结果产生影响，也许是一个很小但可测量影响。人们对此感到惊讶，因为他们认为，
I am just evaluating the candidates and the issues and I'm coming to a relatively reasoned conclusion about which candidate to support. And your theory is, yes, you might be doing that, but there's also something else that's happening in your brain. Well, I think you said I think, and that's the operative phrase that,
我只是在评估候选人和议题，并对支持哪个候选人得出相对理性的结论。而你的理论是，是的，你可能在这样做，但你的大脑中同时还在发生着别的事情。嗯，我想你刚才说了“我想”，这正是关键所在，
yes, indeed, we do cognate most of our decisions generally and most of our political decisions generally, but in this day and age, political decisions are made on a very snap judgment basis level. And when elections particularly nowadays are won and lost and very thin margins, yes, things like partisanship or other perceptions are important, but when it comes down to these little perceptions of faces, voices, things of that nature, especially if you extract partisanship out of it,
是的，确实，我们绝大多数的决策以及绝大多数的政治决策通常都是经过思考的，但在当今时代，政治决策往往是在非常迅速的直觉判断层面上做出的。尤其是当今的选举往往在极其微弱的优势下决定胜负时，是的，党派倾向或其他看法很重要，但当涉及到对面部、声音等微小看法的细节时，特别是如果你排除了党派倾向，
if it's a municipal election, or if it's a primary, where it's Democrats versus Democrats, or Republicans versus Republicans, all of these other things that we bring to the table as animals. Matt. And of course, it's actually makes sense. When we're thinking about sort of leadership and politics, we are thinking in some ways about how coalitions work, who's up, who's down, how our site can win, what's gonna be best for us, what could harm us. I mean, those questions, we might not quite articulate to ourselves in that language,
如果是市政选举，或者如果是初选，即民主党对阵民主党，或是共和党对阵共和党，所有这些我们作为动物带到桌面上来的其他东西都在发挥作用。没错。当然，这其实也说得通。当我们思考领导力和政治时，我们在某种程度上是在思考联盟如何运作，谁占上风，谁处于下风，我们这一方如何才能获胜，什么对我们最有利，什么会伤害我们。我的意思是，这些问题，我们可能不会用那种语言完全清晰地表达出来，
but that is what politics is about. Absolutely. I mean, nowadays, and we've said this in the Coda of many of our papers that, you know, nowadays, obviously politics is about complex ideologies, but at the end of the day, it's about, you know, it's about sticks and stones. And again, not to get too much into the evolutionary psychology waters, but we hold on to that. That is, it is a part of our history, and it plays itself out in modern-day decision-making.
但这就是政治的全部内容。完全正确。我的意思是，如今，我们在许多论文的结语中都说过，如今，显而易见，政治关乎复杂的意识形态，但归根结底，它关乎棍棒和石头。再说一次，并不是要过多地陷入进化心理学的泥潭，但我们确实保留了这一点。那是我们历史的一部分，它在现代的决策中发挥着作用。
Coming up, one dilemma facing the growing number of women running for high office. Political scientist Casey Kloppstead and biologist Rindi Anderson have jointly explored how the pitch of people's voices might communicate important information in the context of politics. Of course, it's very hard when you're looking at an individual race to disentangle all the effects that might be prompting people to vote for one candidate or another. As Casey points out, forces like partisanship influence voters powerfully. Since there are lots of factors that go into winning an election, how do you tell whether the candidate's voice is playing any role?
接下来，越来越多的女性竞选高职所面临的一个困境。政治学家凯西·克洛夫斯塔德和生物学家琳迪·安德森共同探讨了人类声音的音调如何在政治背景下传达重要信息。当然，当你观察一场具体的竞选时，很难厘清所有促使人们投票给某个候选人或其他候选人的因素。正如凯西所指出的，党派倾向等力量对选民有着强大的影响。既然赢得选举涉及诸多因素，你如何判断候选人的声音是否发挥了任何作用？
Casey says the way to do this is through lab experiments that hold the other factors at bay. The lab allows us to take an anecdote, something from the mass media. And as I like to say, and this is not a very scientific term, but I'm going to use any of it, let's put some science on it. Right? Let's take individuals into the lab and give them two experimentally manipulated voices spoken by the same individual, one that happens to be a little bit higher and a little bit lower manipulated by my wife and I.
凯西说，做到这一点的途径是通过将其他因素排除在外的实验室实验。实验室允许我们从一个轶事、一个大众媒体中的事物开始。正如我喜欢说的那样——这不是一个非常科学的术语，但我还是要用它——让我们给它加上一点科学色彩。对吧？让我们把个人带进实验室，让他们听两个经过实验操纵的、由同一个人说出的声音，其中一个碰巧稍微高一点，另一个稍微低一点，这是由我和我妻子操纵的。
And then we say, we don't tell them who's higher low. We just say this is A and B and vote. And we do that dozens of times with a thousand experimental subjects and we get the aggregate average. Now why take in the lab? Causation. What's going on here? Taking an anecdote and putting science on it. And that is what our objective is better. In the experiment, the researchers played a number of clips.
然后我们说，我们不告诉他们哪个高哪个低。我们只说这是A和B，然后投票。我们用一千名实验对象重复这样做几十次，然后得出总体平均值。现在为什么要进入实验室？因果关系。这里发生了什么？获取一个轶事并为其加上科学色彩。这就是我们的目标更好。在实验中，研究人员播放了许多音频片段。
One of them included these two women's voices. Voice A. I urge you to vote for me this November. Voice B. I urge you to vote for me this November. I ask Casey what the experiment found. Voice A was the higher version of voice B was the lower version and these were experimentally manipulated and they were randomized so it wouldn't always be voice A, that's high, voice B is low.
其中一个片段包含了这两位女性的声音。声音A。我敦促大家在今年11月投票给我。声音B。我敦促大家在今年11月投票给我。我问凯西实验发现了什么。声音A是较高版本的声音，声音B是较低版本的声音，这些都是经过实验操纵的，并且它们是随机分配的，所以声音A不一定总是高的，声音B也不一定总是低的。
And the idea is I urge you to vote for me this November, something that's electorally relevant, something that a typical candidate would say, but it's not liberal, it's not conservative. And when you look at a number of these kinds of stimuli when it comes to women's voices in particular, looking just at women's voices, what is your experiment find in terms of the effect that higher pitches and lower pitches have on,
这个想法是“我敦促大家在今年11月投票给我”，这是一个与选举相关的话题，是典型的候选人会说的话，但它既不自由派也不保守派。当你查看许多此类刺激物，特别是在女性声音方面，仅观察女性声音时，你的实验在较高音调和较低音调对以下方面的影响上有何发现：
how much people relate and like the candidate? The effect is we like candidates with lower pitch of voices, regardless of the gender of the voter, regardless of the gender of the candidate, but the bias is a little bit stronger when it comes to women. So to put a pin on it, we like low, regardless of the gender of the voter,
人们与候选人的共鸣程度和喜爱程度？其影响是，我们更喜欢声音音调较低的候选人，无论选民的性别如何，也无论候选人的性别如何，但当涉及到女性时，这种偏见会稍微强烈一些。简而言之，我们喜欢低沉的声音，无论选民的性别如何，
regardless of the gender of the candidate, but the bias is a little bit stronger if we get to female candidates. Casey points to prominent examples in actual politics. One is with Margaret Thatcher and there was an entire movie about it whereby she received vocal training and lowered the timber of her voice.
无论候选人的性别如何，但如果我们面对的是女性候选人，这种偏见会稍微强烈一些。凯西指出了实际政治中的显着例子。一个是玛格丽特·撒切尔，曾有一整部关于她的电影，讲的是她接受了发声训练并降低了声音的音调。
You can go on YouTube and you can find before and after. There's multiple ones of them. And again, these are anecdotes, but this is the idea whereby a woman who had very raw, strong leadership capacity was coached up by her agents and by actors and said, lower the timber of your voice. Margaret Thatcher was the first female prime minister of Britain. You can hear her voice evolve over three decades.
你可以在YouTube上找到前后对比。有好几个这样的视频。再次说明，这些都是轶事，但这个想法是，一位拥有非常原始、强大领导能力的女性，在她的经纪人和演员的指导下被告知：降低你声音的音调。玛格丽特·撒切尔是英国第一位女性首相。你可以听到她的声音在三十年里不断演变。
Some of this was probably caused by aging, but she also deliberately changed the way she spoke. Here she is in the early 1960s. I think it's going to be an even more organizational method. I'm a great believer in those two things. Here she is about a decade later. Margaret Thatcher began taking voice lessons from the Royal National Theatre. In May 1979, she became prime minister. Thank you very much.
其中一部分可能是由于年龄增长造成的，但她也有意改变了她的说话方式。这是她在20世纪60年代初的样子。我认为这将是一个更具组织性的方法。我是这两个东西的坚定信奉者。这是她大约十年后的样子。玛格丽特·撒切尔开始从皇家国家剧院接受声音训练课程。1979年5月，她成为了首相。非常感谢。
How do you feel about this moment? Very excited, very aware of the responsibilities. Her renunciation and delivery became hallmarks of her leadership style. But what the honorable member is saying is that he will rather the poor or poorer provide you the rich or less rich. That way you will never create the will. What do you think is actually happening as we listen to Margaret Thatcher's low-upish voice
你对这一刻有什么感觉？非常激动，对责任有深刻的认识。她的发音和表达成为了她领导风格的标志。但这位尊敬的议员所说的是，他宁愿让穷人或更穷的人提供给富人或不那么富的人。这样你永远也创造不出财富。你认为当我们听玛格丽特·撒切尔较低音调的声音时，实际发生的是什么
versus her higher-pitched voice? What do you think was changing in how listeners were perceiving the candidate? In other words, I think what I'm asking is we know that more people might be willing to vote for the woman with the lower pitched voice, but why is it because they trust her more, they like her more, they respect her more, what's the reason? So initially our experiments just asked, you know, vote up or down, ARB higher low.
与她较高音调的声音相比？你认为听众对候选人的看法发生了什么变化？换句话说，我想我问的是，我们知道更多的人可能愿意投票给声音较低的女性，但为什么呢？是因为他们更信任她，更喜欢她，更尊敬她，原因是什么？所以最初我们的实验只是问，你知道，投赞成还是反对，A还是B，高还是低。
And you played an example earlier of that. What we did in subsequent experiments is we asked who is stronger ARB and who is more competent ARB. And it turns out that those perceptions are highly predictive of whether you voted for low. So to be succinct about it, why do we like candidates with lower voices regardless of their men or women? It's because we perceive them as stronger and more competent.
你之前播放了一个那样的例子。我们在随后的实验中所做的是，我们询问A和B谁更强大，以及A和B谁更有能力。事实证明，这些看法对你是否投票给低沉声音具有高度的预测性。简而言之，为什么无论男女，我们都更喜欢声音较低的候选人？这是因为我们认为他们更强大、更有能力。
If you are thinking of running for political office or you want to get into that corner office, there is an important caveat to keep in mind before you sign up for voice lessons. It's true that voters appear to prefer candidates with low-up pitched voices, but not it turns out when those voices are too low. Yes, we prefer candidates with lower-pitched voices because it can out strength and it can out its leadership abilities. Okay, but if you get too low, for example, vocal fry, vocal fry, right, that is too low,
如果你正考虑竞选公职或想要坐上那个核心办公室，在你报名参加发声训练之前，有一个重要的注意事项需要记住。诚然，选民似乎更喜欢声音较低的候选人，但事实证明，当这些声音太低时则不然。是的，我们更偏爱声音较低的候选人，因为这可以传达力量，可以传达领导能力。好的，但是如果声音变得太低，例如“声带颤音”（vocal fry），声带颤音，对吧，那是太低了，
not a very scientific term, but it is too low, it is out of the average. So the general proposition that we've been talking about with regard to candidates is that low is good, but if you get too low, and particularly if you're a woman, and if you go really low, we don't like it. We find it annoying and the papers that we have published have shown that folks, especially women, but both men and women who speak in a vocal fry, they exaggerate the lower timber of their voice are seen as less trustworthy and actually less hireable.
这不是一个非常科学的术语，但它确实太低了，超出了平均水平。因此，我们一直在讨论的关于候选人的普遍主张是：低是好的，但如果变得太低，尤其是如果你是一位女性，而且如果真的降得非常低，我们就不喜欢了。我们会觉得这很烦人，我们发表的论文表明，人们——尤其是女性，但男女皆是——如果说话带有声带颤音，夸大了他们声音较低的音调，会被视为不那么值得信赖，实际上也不那么容易被录用。
Vocal fry is only one of the landmines that women face when it comes to how their voices are perceived by others. There are separate research that indicates that when women have high-pitched voices, they are perceived to be more attractive. And we've just heard about research that shows that when women have lower-pitched voices, they are perceived to be more competent. Given that getting elected often requires being seen as both attractive and competent, what a female candidate is supposed to do. So women are in a bind.
当涉及到女性的声音如何被他人感知时，声带颤音只是女性面临的地雷之一。还有独立的研究表明，当女性拥有较高的声音时，她们被认为更具吸引力。我们刚刚听说了研究表明，当女性拥有较低的声音时，她们被认为更有能力。鉴于当选往往需要既被视为有吸引力又被视为有能力，女性候选人该怎么做呢？所以女性陷入了两难境地。
As you mentioned, both men and women, lower pitched voices are perceived as more dominant, more competent, and then when we shift to women, that higher pitched voices are perceived as more attractive, and we know that women who are perceived as more attractive are seen as more electable and a number of different studies have shown that. Yes, there is a double standard. We want attractive women in office and yet there are perceptions of their voices sort of contra man's that. So we are living in a
正如你所提到的，无论是男是女，声音较低的人都被认为更有统治力、更有能力，而当我们转向女性时，较高的声音被认为更有吸引力，我们知道被认为更有吸引力的女性被认为更有当选可能，许多不同的研究都证明了这一点。是的，这里存在双重标准。我们希望有吸引力的女性进入政坛，然而人们对她们声音的看法却与此相悖。所以我们生活在一个
modern society, we have culture, we have new standards of how we want to govern ourselves, and yet there are these things that are buried in our hidden brands. There is a certain amount of unfairness in this whole in this whole bias that we have about how voices operate because I understand at a certain animalistic level this might have made sense millions of years ago. It really doesn't make sense in 2012 or 2016 or 2020. Well, and I'm reluctant to put, you know, evolutionary explanations on this, but I mean, were we to delve into those weeds? I mean, where animals? And, you know, it was, it was evolutionary, the adaptive for us to find leaders, be they men or women, mostly men I would presume, back in antiquity, with lower voices, lower voices, corresponds with higher levels of testosterone,
现代社会中，我们有文化，我们有关于如何管理我们自己的新标准，然而，这些东西却埋藏在我们的隐秘大脑中。在我们对声音如何运作的整个偏见中，存在着一定的不公平，因为我理解在某种动物性层面上，这在数百万年前可能是有意义的。但在2012年、2016年或2020年，这确实毫无意义。嗯，虽然我不愿意把演化的解释套用到这上面，但是我的意思是，如果我们深入探讨这些细节呢？我的意思是，我们是动物，而且，你知道的，在远古时期，寻找领袖——无论是男是女，我猜大部分是男性——拥有较低的声音，声音较低与更高水平的睾酮相对应，
which corresponds with higher levels of physical and social aggressiveness. So if we are throwing rocks and we're hitting each other with sticks, I mean, that's a pretty good selection mechanism. And maybe we've held on to that a little bit. But of course, that doesn't always make sense, right? You don't necessarily want the best rock thrower being your representative in Congress. Yeah, absolutely. And that is the rub, right? Are these folks actually better leaders? Are folks with deeper voices actually better leaders? Casey and Rindy asked that question
这与更高水平的身体和社会攻击性相对应，这对我们来说在演化上是具有适应性的。所以如果我们当时在扔石头、用棍子互相击打，我的意思是，那是一个相当不错的选择机制。也许我们多多少少保留了这一点。但当然，这并不总是说得通，对吧？你并不一定希望那个最会扔石头的人成为你在国会的代表。是的，完全正确。这就是症结所在，对吧？这些人真的是更好的领导者吗？声音更低沉的人真的是更好的领导者吗？凯西和琳迪提出了这个问题
in a recent paper. They analyzed the voices of members of Congress in 2008 and compared the timber of those voices against the politicians leadership ability. There was a think tank that came up with a with a ranking of all of the members of Congress, both in the House and the Senate, in terms of various different characteristics, you know, how good or powerful the committees they were on, how long they had been in office, what their vote should, what basically distilling a lot of different characteristics, objective characteristics of their leadership ability, and we're going to give you a score.
在最近的一篇论文中。他们分析了2008年国会议员的声音，并将这些声音的音调与政治家的领导能力进行了对比。有一个智库对众议院和参议院的所有国会议员进行了排名，依据是各种不同的特征，你知道，他们所在的委员会有多好或多强大，他们在任职多久，他们的投票情况，基本上是提炼了许多不同的特征、他们领导能力的客观特征，然后我们要给你打分。
So I had my students about a year and a half ago, gather those data and then go get recordings off of YouTube of those individuals voice pitch. And we did the correlation. We said, is there any correlation between this objective court-on-quote measure that this thing tanked of these individuals and their leadership ability and their voice pitch.
所以我让我的学生在大约一年半前收集了这些数据，然后从YouTube上获取了这些个个人的声音音调录音。我们做了相关性分析。我们说，这个智库对这些个人的客观（所谓的）衡量标准与他们的领导能力和他们的声音音调之间是否存在任何相关性。
What would you think? I would say there would be no correlation whatsoever. You are absolutely correct. There is nothing. Absolutely nothing. And then we did a follow-up study where we did an experiment online whereby we randomly assigned liberal and conservative experimental subjects to listen to liberal and conservative persuasive messages,
你觉得会怎样？我会说两者之间没有任何相关性。完全正确。什么都没有。绝对什么都没有。然后我们做了一项后续研究，我们在网上做了一个实验，随机分配自由派和保守派的实验对象去听自由派和保守派的说服性信息，
things like same-sex marriages or gun control, things of this nature. We randomized it all about. No effect there either. That the timber of the messengers of voice had no effect. So, in real life and in the experimental world, we find that voice pitch actually does not have an influence on leadership capacity. Kasey Klofstad is a political scientist at the University of Miami. His work on the relationship between the human voice and politics was conducted with his wife Rindy Anderson.
比如同性婚姻或枪支管制之类的事情。我们把这一切都随机化了。那里也没有效果。信使声音的音调没有任何效果。因此，在现实生活和实验世界中，我们发现声音音调实际上对领导能力没有任何影响。凯西·克洛夫斯塔德是迈阿密大学的政治学家。他关于人类声音与政治关系的研究是与他的妻子琳迪·安德森共同进行的。
She's a biologist at Florida Atlantic University. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Thomas Liu and Path Shah. It was edited by Tara Boyle, Kimmila Var's Tristrepo and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Jennifer Schmidt and Laura Quarelle. Our unsung hero this week is Sam Turkin. During this interview, I was in a studio in Washington DC and KC was at his home in Florida. We talked over the phone. Sam went to KC's house to record his end of the conversation.
她是一位来自佛罗里达大西洋大学的生物学家。本期 Hidden Brain 由托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）和帕斯·沙阿（Path Shah）制作。由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）、基米拉·瓦尔斯·特里斯雷波（Kimmila Vars Tristrepo）和雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）编辑。我们的团队包括詹妮弗·施密特（Jennifer Schmidt）和劳拉·夸雷勒（Laura Quarelle）。我们本周的幕后英雄是萨姆·特金（Sam Turkin）。在这次采访期间，我在华盛顿特区的录音室里，凯西则在佛罗里达的家中。我们通过电话交谈。萨姆去了凯西家录制了他那部分的对话。
We then combined the two sides of the interview. In audio journalism, this is known as a tape sink, and it's an integral part of how public radio gets made. It takes patience and skill to record a tape sink. If you thought the conversation was clear today, you have Sam to thank. If you liked today's episode, please share it with your friends and think about the voices you hear in your workplace and in your community. Ask yourself, whose voices are missing because they don't sound the way important and influential
然后我们把采访的两部分合并在一起。在音频新闻中，这被称为“磁带同步”（tape sync），它是公共广播制作密不可分的一部分。录制磁带同步需要耐心和技巧。如果你觉得今天的对话很清晰，你得感谢萨姆。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请把它分享给你的朋友，并想一想你在工作场所和社区中听到的声音。问问你自己，有哪些人的声音缺失了，因为它们听起来不像那些重要且有影响力的
people are supposed to sound. I'm Shankar Vidantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
人物应该听起来的样子。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。